[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we had rex chapman on last hour and i
said hey we got jim jackson coming on
the final hour he goes yeah
i think jim put 50 on me so uh
jim was on the call for game seven
between the hawks and 76ers on sunday
night
and uh jim joins us now do you remember
putting 50 up on rex chapman
jim uh
not quite 50 maybe 44. oh
so so you remember exactly 44.
well you know what i don't i don't know
if he was a rex might have been on that
it was uh
that's when they were the washington
bullets okay when we were
and we played them actually it was
ironic then it's the night before i
tore my ankle up when we went to jersey
but i think rex was on that washington
team
uh when that went down a little bit just
a little bit was he guarding you
evidently not
now rex said that he looked forward to
facing vinnie del negro
because he knew he'd probably have a
little easier night who did you oh yeah
who did you look forward to
where you just went oh i gotta circle
that on the calendar
uh you know y'all i'm be honest with you
man it was
during that time i had the ball so much
it really didn't matter
because i was always gonna have a ball
i'm now i had
it was tough two guards at the time to
play against rex was one of them mitch
richmond reggie miller
michael was out of the league right when
i got in because he retired
um clyde drexler it was it never was an
easy night i would say
in the league at that time because then
if you remember centers
two guards and probably power forwards
were your
meat of your um team so it was
never a guardian rex was hard because
rex ran off a lot of screens that
chased him around the whole night you
know that was extremely difficult
how would your game be now if you were
playing
it's a great question you know what it'd
be totally different
you know alonzo morning right good
friend of mine right he said jimmy you
know if i played this era
you know i would dominate i would do it
i said no you wouldn't
he said what do you mean i said because
not that you couldn't you wouldn't be
talented
i said but at the age of 11 and 12 you
wouldn't be posted up on the block
you'll be picking pop three-point
shooter handling the ball
so you'll be a totally different player
and i would be a totally different
player because i was a poster
guard that stayed in the paint mid-range
i got my three-point ball later after my
injury but
i would be a totally different player
just based upon how kids grew up
and played the game than i was when i
played rex chapman brought up the
comparison to ben simmons and he said
jason kidd because jason through
most of his career wasn't a good shooter
didn't want to take the shot
and rex said that they would get mad at
him and say you gotta at least take
shots
so we're not double team when we you
know we come off a pick
your man is going to double team us and
you know i know we're all trying to be
therapist here and uh
psychiatrists with with ben simmons i i
don't know if this is a simple fix
jim what what would you do if if ben is
if you took him under your wing you know
first
i mean that's a great comparison with
jay kidd i didn't think about that but
the difference with jason jason wasn't
afraid to attack
and still get to the basket even though
he struggled sometimes at the free-throw
line early on
jay would never shy back away from
attacking and then still making a play
ben would not now we had to implore
jason to shoot too
early in his career but that turned out
to be great for him
i mean later on and then it's hard to
get into somebody's mind you've been
around the game
games in professional sports enough to
know
that until a person wants to seek help
you can't help them okay if you're still
telling yourself in the mirror
and you look at yourself and say i
really don't need help i can solve it
then there's nothing that advice we can
do look entertain entertainer
have it when they have stage fright okay
people who are public speaking
okay they can be great in front of a
small audience
but get them into a bigger audience and
more people
they don't perform as well so it's not
just a sports thing it's a psyche thing
and until that
individual says i need and will accept
some kind of health
it's really nothing you can do about it
but can you
change his form like at this age he's
going to be 25 in a couple of weeks
can you but it's not but he has good
form that's that's the killer part
dan it's not like he goes up there and
he has a hitch in the shot okay
but he has good form but it's like this
it's a guy that goes and puts into work
ben simmons works on his game people say
well he should go and work
shoot all these free throws he does that
sam cassell we were going out to dinner
in philadelphia
um during the it was game two he's like
i can't go i gotta go to the gym with
ben
at seven o'clock at night and shoot free
throw it's not that he doesn't work on
it not that his form is not there
is that when he gets in the game and
doesn't have immediate this is just me
immediate results all of that goes out
the window
all of that work you put in is left on
the practice court
and that's the difference look at
markelle fultz now
remember detroit struggles mark hill
faults had in philadelphia
sometimes maybe a change of zip code
helped
mark hill folks got out of philly and
now his game has trended
upward mentally he's in a better place
and i'm not blaming it all on philly but
sometimes you need to be removed out of
a situation that's not as comfortable
in order for you to get out of the
uncomfortable situation you're in
yeah i maintain that if you do trade him
you're not going to get dollar for
dollar
but but maybe he goes to a team that
doesn't have the expectations the 76ers
had
when joel embiid is out of their gym he
benes ben feels like looks like plays
like a different player oh yeah
oh totally different i mean he attacks
differently
and i don't know too as if it's one of
those things then where he's comfortable
being
robin you know with joel embiid the
pressure is more on and b
but here i understand the pressure is on
him too but
you made a point and i said this you
know before when embiid is out i mean
out like dnp is going to be out a few
games ben's game is totally different
his mentality is totally different so
which tells us that
if he's in a situation maybe in another
franchise
that's the maybe the mentality that he
has you know 90 95 percent of the time
that he's on the court
i got more concerns with the greek freak
than i do ben simmons
at the line the greek freak can't pull
the trigger he shoots air balls
he doesn't have good form i that's a
bigger concern
but but he's a better player than ben
and and we sort of
whitewashed the other stuff
he's one of the best players in the game
he's shooting air balls jim
from the free throw line yeah but you
know but you know what though let me say
this
carl malone came into the league and he
was like in the mid 40s
free throw shooter yeah ended up
probably over his career in the
mid 70s tim duncan wasn't a great
free-throw shoot
coming into the league but they worked
on it thing i love about greek is this
what you can get on them about shooting
the threes you can get on about the
free throws but at least he's up there
he doesn't leave it on the practice
court like ben does
at times he's not afraid to go and get
fouled
guys feed off of that on your team think
about that too there's some guys that
shot air balls before that a great free
throw shoot
now maybe not as many as giannis has in
his career but
i'm not mad at giannis because at
legianus
has the confidence to take the shot to
get to the basket
in late game situations at times um
and not afraid to be at the free throw
line i think he will become a better
free throw shooter meaning
you know low 70s i think he will because
he works at it he believes
more importantly dan he believes that he
can become a better free-throw shooter
we're talking to jim jackson fox and
turner sports nba analyst he was on the
call game seven
hawks in the 76ers on sunday night we've
been talking about this name
image and likeness for college athletes
uh yeah that that
it's it's happening it's coming our way
but
imagine you're going into college at
ohio state you're a big deal
you know you you could have cashed in
probably uh
big time right locally yeah yeah it you
know what and it's
it's about time but and we got to keep
in mind too it's not like
every player benefits the same because
it's really you know your most popular
players are the ones going to sell a lot
of jerseys
you're in a 52-man roster 55-minute
roster in football
i mean but you gotta have maybe five or
six guys that really benefit
from it i mean big-time benefit that the
university pumps up but still
it's something now i know a lot of
coaches are you know
in between because it's a recruiting
advantage in regards to some aspects
some schools have a bigger alumni base a
bigger tv deal
a bigger this and and they're going to
use that to say well hey
you know if you come to our university
endorsement-wise you're able to pick up
x amount of dollars which is true but
it's still to the benefit of
of the student athlete whether that's
male or female
uh rex said that he was offered 500
000 annuity that that his
his uh they were going to put it in
escrow at school he didn't
say who it was but he said that he was
offered that it through his parents
what was the biggest offer you got right
uh tommy's pizza
that's hobbies pizza bro wait you didn't
get anything
no you were a big deal i'm not if
somebody got something
yeah but i didn't if somebody but we
didn't play that when i came out of my
parents
in the group that i was with coming out
of high school we just didn't go down
that road
we just we never did my father was one
like this look
if you take something from somebody that
means you owe them something
so you think of something dad i worked
all the way through high school
i was a caddy i uh cleaned cars
i worked at uh my grade school mopping
floors waxing floors
always had a job when i was in college
for two years
i worked at dean witter in the summer
for two years and
i sold furniture at value city my junior
year in the summer
imagine me coming up saying okay you
want to get some scotchgard for your
sofa
so i can upsell so i can upsell you to
get more money
okay no let me tell you a story dad it
was
summertime in july a tent sale
outside on morris road
how does all hell get out and i'm out
there
trying to sell a sofa okay but
it's because my father my parents taught
me
that it's you you go
get it you don't have to owe anybody
anything so i feel good about myself
getting that
measly check that i didn't have to worry
about looking over my shoulder
because i didn't take anything from
anybody now i got some free food you
know people would take care of me
and do that kind of stuff but as far as
like greenbacks
nah bro
were you any good at selling furniture
well i would tell you what it's a
competitive business because
hey you notice like when people walk in
the door it's a salesperson that jumps
up on you real quick yeah
that's because you got a percentage of
sale you weren't on salary
bro you had to sell you had to kill what
you eat
okay and man they saw me in there they
was like i don't care this young kid is
not taking my business away
he was tough bro yeah but you had an
advantage you were a big deal you were a
name hey let me tell you something the
looks i got from some of those salesmen
all right i'm telling you bro they
they were listen i was there temporarily
that was their
livelihood oh yeah you think they were
gonna let me
outshine them just because i was jimmy
jackson no bro
no it wasn't happening it was a great
experience though uh
do you think kwai leonard plays in this
series i hope he does but you know
it's interesting because you know i
covered the clippers all year so
they're kind of keeping quiet kind of
what the extent of the injury is
and if they feel that they can get away
but you know there's been a couple games
they can win in phoenix
okay now the home court shifts back to
the clips they go home
maybe they split it still gives kawhi
time enough to get back
instead of rushing it i mean paul george
has been phenomenal yeah i mean i'm
unbelievable i'm so i'm so happy for him
now the story is not written
the story the chapter is not closed but
all year
that i've been saying that paul has just
been focused he hasn't said a lot
he's letting his game do his talking and
right now he's stepping up big time man
yeah i don't know if kawhi plays i know
i i don't i really don't like you know i
expect chris paul back you know probably
when the series goes back to la he's
quarantining in los angeles and and
would probably be able to come back but
without you know what's crazy dan you
know what's crazy is that people talk
about the injuries right
the injuries we were doing a thing on it
that the number of injuries are not that
much higher or lower than the normal
year it's just marquee
it's just the marquee names right now
that's drawing all the attention yeah
you know what i mean and it's
it's tough for the league too because
you you want your guys your key guys
playing it in the year
and injuries are all a part of it but
it's just unfortunate that we had the
rash of
marquee injuries in the playoffs of
anthony davis and murray's
you know now to kawhi you know stuff
like that that
i mean you know with hard and going out
and what what that brooklyn team with
kyrie
you know that totally changes the
narrative of the playoffs you know and
it's tough like that man
it really is have you seen somebody play
better than kevin durant
um that's a great question and it's
because there's been some great
performances
i mean booker is playing awesome right
now devin booker but
it's something different about kevin
durant you know here's the thing i think
you're gonna take and look at kevin like
steph
okay and this is what it's like step
they really don't need the ball in their
hands 85 to be affected
because you can move them around the
board like a chess piece that's why
they're so difficult to guard dan
because
with steph he can throw give the ball up
and run off 18 000 screens and get open
same thing with kd so that makes it more
difficult for the defense to lock in
because
you're just throwing it to him in one
spot or he's just bringing it up the
defense can shift and set
and that kind of can take away some
things but when you can move them around
the court like that how many players
have we seen like that
that have been this effective at 6 11
really seven feet
okay that does that nobody i mean
i was sitting there at all watching it
you know the question was
could he be effective enough without the
other two to to make his team
competitive
i think he answered that question help
me understand this this drives me
crazy when you have everybody knows
kevin durant's getting the ball
there's six seconds to go and and they
have
pj tucker on him so you don't even have
somebody flash on him
you don't you don't have you know
holiday has a chance to go up there i
i got to get the ball out of the star's
hands
yeah like i go back to the utah jazz
against the bulls and michael jordan
they didn't double team him like i know
i mean i know especially especially at
the time too when three-point shot
wasn't
as viable okay but put him in the middle
of the court
almost it's a tougher double team
because you got more options
so i know man it is especially with that
brooklyn team
when kyrie and you know
james are not there it's like when you
play against golden state without clay
on the court it's a lot easier to double
team
steph but yet teams didn't really do it
a lot
early you know to get the ball out of
his head i i don't want the best player
to beat me
if if that if the third guy beats me
then i i live with that
if you said joe harris hits a jumper and
we lose okay
all right but i'm i'm not letting kd hit
hit a jumper i'm not
and you know what if a couple inches
then we're talking about
you know the bucks folding probably
their head coach gets fired
then that's maybe they get healthy and
they win a champion i mean it's that
close and they almost allow that to
happen
yeah i know i know i know and you got to
scratch your head sometimes you think
about it too is that
somebody else is going to have to get
the ball it's just like was a game
i don't know was it tour in brooklyn
when milwaukee
wouldn't allow kd to get the ball or
kyrie and it was
bruce brown who had to try to finish the
shot and somebody
so that right there in itself is what
you're talking about
well you know what it's like when they'd
play a box in one honest
in high school you know i had on us yeah
i like that yeah
yeah we we we can speak french we
because we went through it before but i
we understand it
i i hate it i i would yell at the
defense
i'd say you're afraid to guard me you're
afraid to play that box in one
nonsense let me ask you a question
though when they played the boxing one
or try one two on you
you still were money right no i had to
be a decoy
i had a coach who said get the ball
inside danny get the ball
inside you may need to revisit
your coach man is he is he still walking
and breathing i don't know where he is
[Laughter]
i'm over it jim i'm finally over i can
tell
i'm fine your body language says yeah
it's like you with furniture sales you
know
you're over it right and kinda i'm still
a little scarred man the
the tent cell got me everything else was
fine
i love it here's here's jim jackson
saying you want
you want to scotchgard that yeah
honey it's jim jackson he says you might
bring a scotch guard this yeah yeah
that'll take care of it
i said you got kids right you never know
spillage
village always great to connect with you
jim
thank you buddy i'm here buddy all right
that's uh jim jackson fox and turner
sports nba analysts he's uh the clippers
analyst 14-year nba vet
take a break close-up shop last call for
phone calls what we learn
right after this